If you follow the stock market, you may
have noticed that when news comes out
about a particular company its stock
price can change considerably.
Why is that?
Well, the stock price is of course
the main mechanism by which
investors can essentially let
their view of the stock be known.
In other words, If they think
that the company is buying less,
they're going to sell and
the prices are going to go down.
If investors think the value
of the company should go up,
they're going to buy the stock and
the prices are going to go up.
Now, why is it that this information or
news affects the stock price.
It's based on these things that we've
covered up to now in the lesson.
In other words intrinsic value,
book value, and
well of course, market capitalization.
But let's take a look at how it affects,
say, intrinsic value.
Consider a company run by this CEO and
assume for the moment,
that his business, his company,
is to grow and sell coconuts.
What if the following news comes out?
The CEO is ill.
Maybe he has cancer, maybe he has
something else that prevents him
from collecting those coconuts as
effectively as he might otherwise do.
Well, certainly that should affect
the stock price downward because
the probability that we are going to get
dividends in the future is decreasing.
Either that or the amount of
the dividends is going to decrease.
So, if you think back to the intrinsic
valuation that we talked about.
The potential for
reduced future dividends reduces
the value of the company significantly.
Now consider another scenario
where's there's an island
with our original company and
another company.
And news comes out about the soil
on the island being contaminated.
That news is going to affect not
only our original company, but
also all the other
companies on the island.
So you can think of this sort
of news as being sector news.
In other words it relates to the sector
of growing coconuts on this island and
it affects all the companies
in this sector.
let's consider one last
scenario were we have many
islands with many
companies on those islands.
And news that might effect all
of them like sea level rising,
that is going to negatively
impact all of these companies.
So we have examples here of
companies specific news that affects
the price of an individual company.
Sector-specific news that effects, say,
the companies on a particular island or
in a particular industrial segment.
And market-wide news that affects
all the companies in the market.
So that's how news can effect
the prices of the stock.
Primarily because they reduce
the expectation of future dividends.
We've seen how that can affect
the intrinsic value and
accordingly, why people would
want to pay less for that stock.